one of the sort of fun things to watch lately.
And it's fun in the sense of of it being a
disaster porn, quite frankly, it's been to
see not only the radicalization of right wing
media like Newsmax and on, but also seeing
the low rent characters that have been introduced
to us through these networks.
So we've come to know people like Sidney Powell
and Lin Wood, Mike Lyndell from my my pillow,
or as I like to call them, Mike Pillow, the
various hosts and reporters on OCN and Newsmax
who either couldn't get jobs at serious news
outlets or used to work there and were laid
off or quit or got fired or whatever the case
may be.
I have a new one for you today.
All right.
Newsmax interviewed a woman named Rachel Hame.
That's with two Ms. M-m Rachel Hamm is a barely
known radical right wing Christian.
I have no idea why Newsmax even wanted to
interview her, but they did.
And she went on air and she said Donald Trump
has been the best thing for Christianity since
Jesus.
Yeah, like Jesus Christ.
You know, the guy.
Listen to this.
She is responding to claims that some have
made that Donald Trump has not been a good
Christian nor good for Christianity.
Rachel Ham believes he has been great, in
fact, a catastrophe for Christianity.
Well, I have to laugh at President Trump was
the best thing to happen to the Christian
church in America since maybe Jesus.
So, yeah, that's ridiculous.
I read the article.
I thought if it weren't, I don't know.
I don't know if he actually believed the things
he was saying, but he is not in touch with
what the evangelical church thinks at all.
So, OK, Trump, the best thing for Christianity
since Jesus.
It sounds sort of weird, but this is a woman
who's been invited to speak, so she must know
what she's talking about.
Right.
But I don't know.
I have no idea why she's on TV.
We researched Rachel Ham.
She has a YouTube channel with twenty three
thousand subscribers, OK?
She wrote a book called Life Beginning, which
is about her connection to God.
And she has a website where she sells online
courses and e-books and she will give you
advice and this type of thing.
So I don't know what's more sad, that this
is the person that Newsmax was able to get
to talk about how great of a Christian Donald
Trump is or was or that Newsmax is even willing
to have Rachel Ham on to make these claims.
Like, I don't know who's dragging down who
it's not completely clear to.
And this, by the way, is another example of
the unhealthy level of idolizing politicians
that I've been warning about for years now,
I've warned the left and right about this
when I saw cults of personality developing
around Tulsa or Andrew Yang or Bernie, whoever,
like, agree, disagree with people's politics.
I think it's a bad idea to defy any politicians
that includes the left and the right.
This is taking it to the extreme, the best
for Christianity since Jesus.
This is very, very I mean, again, you know,
these seem like sick people to me.
To me, this doesn't seem like it's someone
who's emotionally well placed within within
the world.
But so much like we've been talking about
the Republican Party becoming more about performative
outrage, this is another element of modern
Republicanism that is either going to destroy
the party or they'll have to rule it, route
it out.
I don't know that this is a party that I mean,
you know, a lot of us obviously don't take
people like Rachel Hamm nor Newsmax seriously
as it is.
But to the extent that Newsmax will play a
role in the modern right wing movement and
the Republican Party or the party, if Trump
decides to create a third party, this is not
going to be you know, you and I might say
it's it's obviously humiliating.
They won't see it that way.
But I still don't think it's useful because
there are Republicans who find this type of
nonsense just not good politics.
They think it's unproductive for them.
And that's often that's often the strongest
word they're willing to use.
It's not productive.
Sort of like Susan Collins being perpetually
disappointed by what Donald Trump did.
It's kind of a toothless phrase.
But in any case, it is going to be a drag
on the Republican Party.
And this is this is a real challenge.
You know, for years we've been hearing demographic
shifts mean Republicans will never win Texas
again.
And so far they keep winning Texas.
Maybe at some point the demographic shifts
will take Texas from Republicans.
This combination of factors seems very serious.
A 64 percent of Republicans willing to leave
the party and follow Trump to a third party.
As we talked about earlier, the conservative
media audience increasingly split between
Fox News Max 018 and others, the Trumpy, Marjorie
Taylor Greene, Lauren Bobert Madison, Cawthorn,
wing of the Republican Party, increasingly
at odds with people like Mitt Romney, not
exactly a liberal by any stretch of the imagination.
All of these things together really could
spell disaster for the Republican Party.
I hope it happens and we'll continue following
it.